but we're holding on
why is it happening to us why did he
come to us
it's too much for someone
since march i haven't been able to reach
my mother in mario paul the house was
hit by four shells the police offer a
vital lifeline for these people
south africa is the worst hit area of
kharkiv
few live here even fewer venture here
this is building 225 on friendship of
nations street
the irony is another nation's soldiers
stand a few kilometers away obliterating
this neighborhood
there's more people over there can you
evacuate them they have disabled
children asks this resident
we can only evacuate people if you have
somewhere to house them
all the metro stations are full
says officer yan
but still there's more
we're taken to a basement
let's go go go go go go go watch your
hand pitch black darkness ah he's got
torches
one room
then another
and finally
oh
among those crammed into this room we
find six-year-old kiera
she's preparing for school
a school that may never open
she wants to be a break dancer and
recites a poem about the love for a
mother
[Music]
and says his daughter hasn't been
outside for two weeks
this is every 20 to 30 minutes it's
normal it's normal if it wasn't for the
shelling my daughter would be outside
break dancing
guys
be careful be careful
for the police accompanying us this is
personal
they all used to live in this
neighborhood
jan still has a home here
the only way to get in is through the
window
he doesn't live here anymore
but passes by from time to time to check
up on it
you guessed it
today the flat is intact and whole
tomorrow it might not be great
thank you russia
incoming
the shells fall nearby
stay where we are until uh to stop
firing
it'd be crazy to try and get outside
into a basement now
in the open space
just stay cool
al jazeera kharkiv